in their franchise history the charges
have had only two instances where a
player gained 100 yards rushing and
receiving in the same game the first was
lionel james in 1985 against the bengals
who was the other and here's the hint it
happened last season
austin eckler
there is the horn i mean are you kidding
me with that
[Laughter]
kidding
i i don't write the questions you know
that every once in a while it's a very
easy one and the hint the hint kind of
put that one over the top without the
head who would have known you would have
said ladainian tomlinson
right no i would have said austin eckler
because i just wrote about him the other
day yeah it's the jacksonville jaguars
he had a hundred hundred there it is
there it is all right all right peter
gets the first pick
can i go
okay let's go
my first guy my first guy who i'm
picking even though statistically
i got a couple of other guys who i like
a lot better i'm gonna pick tyron
matthew because to me tyron matthew
in 2019
was the impact player that pushed the
kansas city chiefs over the top
with
for large a large portion of the year
was a mediocre defense he willed those
guys playing all over the map
in the back seven he willed those guys
to the super bowl and at the end of the
year i remember
you know talking to andy reid after one
game and andy reid said basically he had
two guys talk to his team that week one
of them was patrick mahomes because
mahomes had become even at the age of 24
a major team leader and the other
was tyron matthew even though he was in
his first year with this team he was the
most respected guy on that defense so i
give my number one pick in this draft to
tyron matthew strong pick there peter
strong strong pick i was thinking about
taking him first for all the reasons you
said too i mean it go the hell with
stats it does more than that he changed
the
the just the team in general the the
tenacity in which they played he had
leadership he gave them you know
something to stand on on the defensive
side of the ball and the the defense has
been crappy for a lot of years he gave
him some confidence and swag so that's a
great pick by you uh i was thinking
about taking him with my number one pick
as well i'm gonna go with shaquille
barrett i mean come on you want to talk
about like not having to pay a big money
and then getting results i mean shaq
barrett i mean led the nfl 19 and a half
sacks i mean that's got to be the best
dollar for dollar value you could
possibly get with free agent signing i
mean a guy of that stature that puts up
that type of numbers as we got as we
know you know they can command 18 20
million dollars a year and i'm sure that
he might get some deal like that from
the tampa bay buccaneers if they can
figure out something like that as far as
after franchise tagging them and then
signing them but either way it was a
phenomenal year by a guy who's been a
really good player and was stuck in a
tough spot in denver prior to this and
then of course exploded when he got in
the right system and got his opportunity
with the tampa bay buccaneers
okay my pick and that's a good one that
was going to be mine
because i thought you were going to make
a different pick and i thought you were
going to make a pick to which i was
going to strenuously object because
you've done this before when we've had
similar categories you've taken two guys
and pushed them into one do you know
what i'm talking about i do you know
what i'm talking about you're talking
i'm talking about zadarius and preston
smith no in green bay yes zadarius and
preston smith package deal sims has
already crossed that boundary i thought
he was going to do it again he didn't
give me that they transformed the pass
rush in green bay and and and also
provided like a new attitude hey the
packers aren't just going to sit back
and draft and develop they are going to
make moves when they need to to make the
team better the leadership that zadaria
smith brought to the table was special
for the packers aaron rodgers praised
those decisions to bring in guys like
that who have that leadership quality so
it worked out well for the packers not
well enough they didn't get to the super
bowl but they had a much better year
than anyone expected in large part
because of zadarius and preston smith
yeah hard to argue that okay
i'm gonna you know i i really wanted
zadarius smith um
and and i i thought of preston smith and
i probably should take him because he
was great too not as great as a darius
but i'm gonna go with a guy who became
because i'm sort of big on veteran guys
who come in for reasonable money
and they make their team so much better
in part by their presence
okay and so i'm gonna pick mark ingram
gosh you know he basically turned down
the same money
in new orleans to go to baltimore i mean
relatively the same money
and it's almost like he went to
baltimore because he wanted to spread
his wings and he wanted to be the guy
watch him coming out of the tunnel right
here he wanted to be the guy to go to
the podium and say i'm here get on my
back we're going to win it all and
because that's the attitude this guy has
he had it the whole year
he played better than i thought he would
play both in the running and passing
game he made it possible
basically in my opinion for lamar
jackson to do a lot of the crazy things
that he did because
everybody said hey we got to stop mark
ingram and so to me i think mark ingram
basically outplayed the value of his
contract i think a lot of people around
the nfl were surprised in that but he's
my easy second round pick here
yeah that's another good one i mean it's
right along the lines with your first
pick there honey badger you know it
changes the locker room changes the
attitude of a football team you know his
his ability to hit the hole and hit it
at 100 miles per hour and have no
hesitation
makes lamar jackson keeping the ball off
the edge that much more dangerous all
right
i'm not sure what the rules are of this
draft okay but
like oh well oh
hey something's gonna happen well we
know like anybody that's tagged and
traded right has got to be part of this
conversation that's part of free agency
right
well to me you know this maybe doesn't
classify as a free agent signing but it
happened during free agency okay and
this is what i'm going with ryan
tannehill i mean come on
can we make that or no is that not
here's the thing here's the thing here's
the thing
if it takes you that long to explain why
you're doing it you know in your heart
you shouldn't be doing it well why well
okay but
there's players like joe devion clowney
too where he didn't get traded until the
summer time but it was part of the the
free agency and him getting tagged so
like does he count i thought you were
gonna go frank clark or d ford simple
tag and trade ryan tannehill was under
contract there was no tagger trade he
was just a guy who was under contract
who was traded he's not part of the free
agency discussion no i i have ruled i
need a gap okay
i'll take that that's fine i just needed
some ruling just needed some leadership
here on the show
sustained okay
that that that all right my other pick
then i'm gonna go with teddy bridgewater
i'm gonna go with teddy bridgewater even
though it's not the sexiest thing in the
world he makes my list a little bit for
the reasons like you know peter has
mentioned one you know hey good backup
it does improve the locker room two
i mean he went 5-0 as a starter you know
it was a brilliant move by sean payton
and the saints to bring him in you know
they're a super bowl team he wasn't
going to take the chance of oh man drew
brees gets hurt and all of a sudden
we're out of the playoff race right so
teddy bridgewater even though i'm not so
sure he's a starting quarterback in
football i think he's really just a
great great backup that was a huge free
agent signing last year you know he gave
them a chance to still be a first-round
buy team because he went 5-0 as a
starter with the new orleans saints so
to me that was one of the bigger uh 2019
off-season signings that was out there
um i see and i
maybe maybe you're operating on a higher
level than the rest of us chris maybe
you deliberately cross the line with
both feet on tannehill so we wouldn't
give you a hard time about teddy
bridgewater
he did it wasn't a free agency he he
stayed with the saints how was that a
free agency signing his contract expired
and he signed a new one and then he
stayed with the saints okay what's wrong
with that he was a free agent he was
free technical word there lawyer man was
the free part right and then well
there's a lot of guys there's a lot of
guys that you can anybody who resigns
with their team
uh is is coming from the guy who took
two guys with one pick you can't talk
shut up your jurisdiction has run it
over be quiet
i'll trade the two i'll trade the two
guys for one finger i'll tell you that
right now all right am i up yes uh all
right uh i i am going to actually keep
within the spirit of the draft and i am
going to pick a quarterback who did
change teams last year did he change
teams ryan fitzpatrick miami dolphins
was that his second year there or his
first oh whoa
you don't even know your own pick
all i know is i'm taking ryan
fitzpatrick you've already crossed that
boundary if he was with the dolphins
before that then who cares he ended up
being very good last year he was the
team mvp he was with the supplier by
josh rosen okay so good then i am in my
in my appropriate lane with this ryan
fitzpatrick miami dolphins best
quarterback on the roster last year mvp
of the team and helped them
catapult into respectability when it
looked like they were going to fall
apart early in the year once they
decided to stick with him they turned
into a team that was competitive last
year and there is some vague sense of
hope now for 2020 brian fitzpatrick
okay so my third round pick i'm gonna go
straight free agent and i'm gonna give
you a guy who nobody would really think
of on this list and that is kareem
jackson so the denver broncos signed
kareem jackson thinking
that he likely was going to be a
cornerback for him but he gets to camp
and he last year he and justin simmons
formed the best safety tandem in the nfl
last year and i think one of the things
that you appreciate about a guy like
kareem jackson is while he's very good
in coverage okay
he is a hitter he reminds me almost of
you know sort of this kind of hybrid guy
who can play any spot in the back end
those guys are so rare in football but
he had a very good year and he
contributed basically to the denver
broncos thinking right now that the
strength of our team right now is our
defensive secondary and it's so good
that there's a chance that we're just
going to be able to let chris harris
walk out the door that's how good our
secondary is so to me i like kareem
jackson here and i'll take him as my
third round pick wow i mean you just
you're killing it today you're killing
it i mean you won the draft i'm just
telling you right now i love meets and
corinne jackson and you're right he's a
swiss army knife gonna be can do a lot
of different things um you won the draft
i'm giving you that title
all the way there all right you know
what i'm gonna go i'm gonna go to
i'm gonna go with richie incognito and
the raiders okay
as much i like that one yeah i mean i i
like you know i'm in the spirit of what
you're doing like some under the radar
guys that deserve a little credit and
richie incognito as much as he's been a
knucklehead off the field you know one
thing i was told by people out in
oakland now the las vegas raiders was
wow
he was unbelievable in the locker room i
think that shocked people his leadership
there but secondly
i mean he was in the conversation for
one of the best guards in football last
year and i don't think that can be you
know we can't deny that talk you know no
matter what what you think of the guy or
whatever he is still a really good
football player and that is to me again
the value they didn't have to spend a
whole lot of money to get him they gave
him another chance really and you know
it delivered in a big way for them and
uh he certainly played some really good
football last year
all right i am going to once again go
with a two pack since there's nobody
else to draft behind me i'm taking call
beasley and john brown receivers signed
by the buffalo bills to help get more
out of josh allen oh and it worked yes
what no no you're not taking two guys
you are not taking two guys
i already did it that's it you're not
picking four you're not picking
all right i'll take john brown uh
anyway two-pack
because both got because it's the same
position and i know it's different guys
one's down the field and the other's a
slot receiver but the whole idea was
then i mean jerry smith and preston
smith
i already did that come on play the game
the right way
mister i already did it
all right geez boy i got chris going and
now peter's chiming in thank god we're
not all together you guys would be
throwing me against the wall and i'd
like the body's slamming me yeah all
right uh and i would tase you for a
thousand dollars we're gonna take a
break what you'll be talking about today
including
rob gronkowski about to sign a new
contract for an athletic endeavor sort
of we'll talk about that next year on
pft live
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports